almost 20 years since since 9/11 we have
just been pounded over and over and over
again at some point that thing is so
rickety and has so many holes in it that
a Black Swan event will collapse it and
I think we are a war a a serious
economic shock um a mass killing a
terrorist
attack that's when things will change I
I think we're on the edge of
we could have a dictatorship from either
direction if we're not careful we have
to know the Constitution know our rights
be God loving um God-fearing humble
people that when something goes wrong we
do what we used to do join hands with
one another and say brother I'm here for
you let's we can get through this but
we're in a place to where I think